Dr.
My name is I would like to ask one short
question. Some argue that Islamic dress
codes for women are very restrictive
and
>> sorry they are very
>> restrictive
>> restrictive.
>> How does Islam balance modesty with
choice? And second also how can woman
avoid materialism while maintaining
selfrespect?
>> This has a question that many people say
that the hijab be restrictive. How can
they maintain the modesty and how can
they maintain the selfrespect? As far as
the Islamic Sharia is concerned, there
are six criterias in the Islamic hijab.
The main vers of the Quran is surah
nurse number 31 and surah a chapter 33
verse number 59. And there are six
criteria for hijab. Number one is extent
which differs from the man to male and
the female. For the male it's from the
navl to the knee. For the women the
complete body should be covered. The
only part that can be seen are the face
and hands of the wrist. Some scholars
say this should be covered. The
remaining five criteria are the same.
The clothes should not be so tight so
that it reveals the figure. Number two.
Number three, the clothes should not be
transparent or translucent so that you
can see. Three, see through. Number
five, it should not number four, it
should not be so glam so that it
attracts the opposite sex. Number five,
it should not resemble that of the
opposite sex. Women should not wear
clothes of the men. Men should not wear
clothes of the woman. And number six,
you should not wear clothes that which
resemble that of the other religion. You
cannot wear a cross. You cannot wear
tika. So if someone says this is
restrictive, it is not. It's protecting
[laughter] them. If Islam has uplifted
the woman and given her equal right,
Allah has also prescribed how to protect
it. That is the Allah says in surah a
chapter 33 verse number 59. Oh prophet
tell your wives and your daughters and
the believing women when they go about
they should put on the jpa the old so
that they shall be recognized and it
will prevent them from being molested so
that the woman shall be recognized that
she's a modest woman. It's not
restrictive at all. It is protecting
when you go in the cold air you wear
fur. NO NO NO I DON'T WANT TO BE FUR. I
don't want to be restricted then you
will die of cold right or wrong if you
go in a snow area where there 10 - 20
-30 I don't want to be restricted I want
to go bare body you will die so here
also for modesty Allah has prescribed
you
and you can be any color if you have
white color you have to change every day
if you have black color you have to
change after every one so the color is
your choice it should not be glamorous
so all these are rules and regulations
that has been mentioned in the Quran and
the Sai hadith. This is to protect your
modesty. So you follow this rule, you'll
be protected. If you don't follow, then
there are high chances that your modesty
is broken. Hope that's our first
question.